I want you to notice make sure those
you've got these asymptotes got these
asymptotes so if you change the a and
the B right remember what they're
changing is proportions yes it is
stretchy or squashing or very more
squashing okay but what they gonna do is
give us fatter or thinner or bigger
versions of this there's no way you can
start from that form and get to a graph
like this why is that how does it break
thing why is it impossible because you
type number one we've got like we've got
hasn't psychotics of crossover but more
importantly because you might measure
big asymptotes I actually came across
what we can take more of these shoe is
like how do you get these things we
found for this you can't possibly get
real values that can satisfy that you
come right so this is a hyperbola that
is already to horizontally okay in order
to get however that's oriented very
clean
you notice how there are no x-intercepts
long as you read one right so what's
gonna happen is these two guys are going
to switch around your switch around okay
so it's going to look like this I need a
new boy I'm gonna have Y squared
okay now this guy's important it's very
important
I'm gonna give you the name in a second
but I just wanted you a tiny little bit
of algebra to show you what's going to
happen with you do you notice if I try
and work with this and start doing all
of this let's just think about the
asymptotes as any table okay what
happens when I start to calculate well I
still want to get Y squared is the
subject of in why I've been doing this
to the new stuff right watch what
happens on the next line watch I'm going
to get rid of the x squared term and it
just turns into this right now they're
carefully compare it to what I just did
do you notice what I just do everything
looks the same except that's a plus
do you agree right that's gonna be a
plus so that means that's gonna be a
plus and that and that so now what
happens I think this and the answer is
that thing is still approaching zero so
therefore as experts infinity why still
gonna approach that this hyperbola has
exactly the same as it is so you're
getting this kind of configuration
whether approaching the same thing you
should orient differently okay so
tomorrow whether we introduced
introduced last lesson which kind of
just means well it's like a hyperbola
but it's the other one we call this we
call this the conjugate
the clergy gonna have ever it's the
hyperbola that shares the same
asymptotes as whichever other hyperbola
yeah but instead of being oriented this
way it's very oriented the other way
it's gonna hit the other coordinate axes
okay yeah
one last thing before we leave all of
this stuff and particularly figure out
these asymptotes are they're quite a
useful G's notice there's a special case
for the asymptotes if these two numbers
a B if they are equal to each other
right they're not just off at random
ankles if any equals B right the many
behavior is a very special case when a
equals B that fraction B every is just
one so what you get is this okay so
these two asymptotes here are going to
be at right angles right do you see that
like once 1 plus X 1 minus X now B that
they have right angles the hyperbola the
specific kind of hyperbole you get
refers we call that the rectangular
hyperbola and you might say what where
are the rectangles in there
and the answer is remember what I just
told you and the acetones
they're at right angles in fact that's
exactly what rectangle means like you
whistle familiar rectangles being a
shape that has four right angles in it
but actually rectangle just means right
angle so for example when you rectify
something it's like something's wrong
and you rectify it you make it right so
a rectangle is literally a right angle
so really
this shape really the shape the gym this
should be called a quad rectangle but I
guess that's a big concern at the forum
but I guess that's a bit awkward so it's
their corner right - well yeah because
it's got four sides but it just happens
to be the other side okay so when we say
the rectangular hyperbolas we are
looking at at um the asymptotes are at
rectangles okay they are writing those
to each other now by the way this is not
the only rectangular hyperbola in fact
then all of the hyperbola you've been
dealing with for a very long time have
been retained in my hypo what was the
first type of do you ever met was one of
them's right what it is hold on a second
under one on X figure out what an X for
a second we know exactly what the cool
side he's the first quadrant he's the
third of where the asymptotes and the
answer is they're already there right
there they are the coordinate axes and
they are at right angles right almost
every other one you've also drawn has
been like this - like if I do something
like okay y equals just to think about
what you know about this thing
okay I'll do the super quick version
always wanted very much of the scale
where's the other where's the easiest
asymptotes to identify i say x equals 3
are you going to get something
and then because this whole thing as X
approaches infinity is going to go off
to zero
you're gonna fridge y equal 1 but you
need me up here right now I think I've
done a number of myself I think this is
gonna be oriented backwards but you can
see the important thing is the
asymptotes are at right angles
it's another rectangular hyperbola it's
just well number one it's obviously it's
it's been moved away from the argument
that number two it's being rotated okay
in fact these hunters are more familiar
with are these guys at 45 degrees and
that's why they have quite different
equations alright so in conclusion what
have we looked at so if I want to be
established okay you know how to work
with the Lipsey's and find their
features okay the reason why I had
purple are come later
is because even though a lot of it is
the same a lot of it's the same there
are more features and they're a little
bit trickier to work out not only are
there more features there are sort of
different categories of high-poverty you
need to keep in your mind as well
because they will make to each other
important way and lastly the thing that
we just looked at was that in an ellipse
in other layers if a and B are equal
what shape do you get you get a circle
right if a and B are equal in a
hyperbola we get this guy right all the
proportions are kind of nice and equal
and that's white got those
yeah kinda high if you think about it
this way a circle and an ellipse they're
kind of its public lands facing inwards
and then if you cut it in that right
direction you get the part that's facing
outwards right so that's why it's quite
amazing go have a look at the thing that
you should look up a lot really curious
and I think you know why
Oh guys look up these days
not tainted I am as you know this fella
dead Berlin spheres either geometric
construction involved in proving that
all of these 2d shapes come from this 3d
thing it's quite profound it's a pretty
heavy-duty mess but it's really
interesting